[Music]
four months before the election the
political parties were preparing with
ads on Facebook then on October 28th the
election was announced and this happened
so who's doing the spending if you look
at the main Facebook pages for each
party
it's the Conservatives followed by the
other parties all around the same level
but our analysis which look to all the
party political actors show something
slightly different the brexit party is
flagging have they lost momentum that is
the rumor in Westminster and the digital
evidence suggests it's true so what does
that money buy it buys these ads with
lots of views the top 8 viewed ads all
come from the Conservatives often as you
just saw with minor tweaks but they
together gathered a total of 3.5 million
views it's not until you get to the
ninth fad that you see off from Labour
and the most viewed Lib Dem ad ranked
21st the brexit party their way back in
26th i'm good.how you what's been on
your mind today
well I can't hide it from you I've been
thinking a bit about this general
election campaign do these ads work
videos like this one you're seeing now
show the Conservatives are trying to
learn the lesson of 2017 when they spent
big on ads but we're let down by lack of
shareable content but our research
suggests they still have some way to go
because low effort posts like this one
from Labour which is on a very emotive
topic but he's actually just a
screenshot of a tweet regularly do
better than anything that conserved if
you have on Facebook one last thing
another place where the competition is
hotting up is Google well we found
42,000 pounds in ad spending look the
brexit party had bought ad for the
phrase labour and if you see here the
the Conservatives have bought an ad for
the phrase Lib Dems this is a very
cunning little trick here the
Conservatives bought an ad for the
phrase postal voting which redirects
here to this site which asks for your
name
your your address and also your email
information which condemn used to target
you of course on Facebook welcome to the
digital campaign it is just getting
started
[Applause]